Hello, this is Frank Defratis, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk for the week of February 1st, 1999.
We have a very interesting guest this week, John Clare, who packs his holography equipment up and takes it down into caves to make holograms of the formations.
John just made his first laser pointer hologram, so he's happy he doesn't have to tie the heavy power pack around his leg to crawl for over an hour to get where he's going inside the cave.
Just pop the pointer in his pocket, and he's good to go.
Now we have quite a few updates this week on the laser pointer front, but I'm going to save the details for next week's show.
Reports are coming in from others now making holograms using a laser pointer, and it's very encouraging.
One person from Norway had his helium neon laser quit on him over the holidays, and now he's not going to replace it.
Steve Michael should have a new report by next week, and I'll be here to tell you about my own experiment using solar power to run my laser pointer, eliminating the needs for batteries entirely.
You can read my first report on this on the laser pointer page.
This past week.
So this upcoming week on Holotalk, I'll be running some testing to see how things work out, and I'll report on this as well on next week's show.
Now, my guest John Clare contacted me last year, at the end of the year, just as Steve and I began to put up information on making holograms with laser pointers.
He was very interested in this because he has to lug his helium yarn laser along with a very heavy motorcycle battery down into the caves with him.
He ties the motorcycle battery to his leg as he crawls through the tight crevices that leads to the larger cathedral underground rooms.
For John, being able to make holograms using a laser pointer is a dream come true.
He just needs to pop the pointer in his pocket and off he goes.
Now he just made his first successful laser pointer hologram this week, and he's looking to head into the caves to try it out down there very soon.
I had a lot of fun talking with John, and I think he's doing something that's very unique with holography, and I hope you enjoy the interview.
We'll be right back after this quick message.
Would you like to make your own one-of-a-kind hologram and learn how you can start making holograms on your own at the same time?
You can do this and much more by attending one of Frankie Freitas' holography workshops.
From beginner to advance, Frank's got a workshop that's just right for you.
From single afternoon, evening, or weekend introductory workshops to Wednesday evening five-week complete courses.
And don't forget his newest workshop, Razor Pointer Holography.
Located just off the Northeast Extension of the Pennsylvania Turnpike and Interstate 78.
The studio is a quick nonstop drive from the New York, Philadelphia, and Baltimore, Washington, DC areas.
For more information, call the studio's toll-free hotline at 1-800-458-3525 and begin your own journey with holography today.
That's 1-800-458-3525.
For more information on attending a Frankie Brad's holography workshop today.
John, how are you?
All right.
Oh, that's that's perfectly okay.
I I was four times it's not cheap to do that.
No, it's okay.
I wasn't quite sure if we were in the same time zone or not, so I figured maybe you were is it okay, ten o'clock now?
It's not too late for you, is it?
Yes.
But if I remember right, with the email that you sent me the other night, you were like painting a hologram black at four in the morning, aren't you?
Yeah, I don't know.
Is that Sunday night or Monday night or what I remember doing that?
Well, I know I know those times.
I'll tell you what, doesn't that paint can when you shake it with the marble in it sound like ten times as loud in the middle of the night?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm always thinking they wake the whole neighborhood up.
Because I usually go outside and spray it.
And I'm standing outside shaking this paint can, and you can hear it throughout the whole neighborhood at four o'clock in the morning.
So we're we're talking with John, is it Clayer?
Uh huh.
Okay, John Claire.
I just wanted to make sure that I got the last name pronounced because we've we've been back and forth with email, but we really haven't talked to one another until just now.
And uh John does something that I think is so unique, uh that I've never heard about it before now.
Now most of the times when people make holograms, they're in a laboratory or a studio environment.
But John actually takes his equipment down into caves, right?
Right.
Well you no uh you try to set up a holography table you want to get into a basement onto the bedrock hole wouldn't be better except to get down into the bedrock.
Now tell me something, do you have any isolation that you take down there or is that is that cave so still and so isolated that you just shoot right at whatever's in there.
Right, just the the formation and uh take a piece of uh holographic uh plate and set it up against there and you know give it a couple of seconds to settle and then you do your shoot.
Now you were using the helium neon laser right why don't you tell us some of the trouble that you have to go through to get a helium neon laser 'cause most helium neon layers uh lasers obviously run off of electricity but uh I'm sure you don't have any receptacles down there in the cave, right?
Of course not what do you have to do to get power down there.
Well it's just uh take I guess they call it a motorcycle battery which is uh kind of a heavy device back down there and then the the laser itself you know neon's about a foot and a half long and uh it's kind of a rough journey getting into the cave so I put it inside of a piece of I guess four inch uh P V C pipe with some uh padding and all inside of it.
Well okay, yeah that's a good idea.
Uh and then uh limit it to five milliwatts 'cause that's the biggest uh D C power supply I could find was you know power a five million.
I thought I could add a ten million.
Now we've got these diodes now.
Yeah, what do you think about that?
Now you've got a couple of batteries and that's it, you know.
You did a hologram the other night using your diode, right?
Right.
And then it turned out pretty good for you.
Turned out beautiful.
Great.
Well the first two I did uh didn't turn out so well, but uh the third one, I don't know, just uh third third time was a charm, I guess.
Yeah, th reports are starting to come in from people who are doing these diodes and even myself, my first one I did one around Christmas time, I just grabbed my wife's frosty the snowman and and put it there.
And it was rather dim.
And I think what happens is everyone's so excited just to see if this works and they just rush through everything and don't take the time like I did.
I didn't take time I didn't take a lot of time with it.
I wanted to really see if this would work.
And it's usually the second or third one.
Once you see that you at least can get something.
Yeah, that might be possible.
Well, you slow down a little bit and take a little bit more time with the uh uh pro uh with the uh actual exposure and the processing and and and it really pays off.
Well I grabbed the hid hair dryer right away too.
Yeah.
Okay.
And the third time I just did let it set for a while and it uh naturally dry before I hit it with a hair dryer.
Now how long have you been doing this?
Probably back in the seventies sometime, uh maybe about seventy three or seventy four I first started and now is this first starting on?
I'm not a professional holographer or anything, it's just a hobby.
Uh-huh.
Now you started making holograms back in the seventies, is that what you're saying?
Yeah.
Wow.
And you were doing it in caves as well.
Well, no, I tried doing it a cave way back then, but uh they didn't have these nice little uh power supplies.
Oh, okay, yeah.
I tried dragging uh a homemade uh inverter and all back in there and uh now how did you get involved with holography in the first place?
Are you uh a technical person, artistic or uh how would you describe yourself and your involvement with holography?
Well that's just fun to know when I first heard about it back in the sixties when I was in high school and fascinated and wanted to do it and um just couldn't wait till I uh got a hole of enough money to buy a lace.
Try it myself.
Yeah.
Did you have like a five millatt back then or something?
Oh no, I think it was a two or three million.
Yeah.
The old fashioned ones that had the epoxy seals on them.
Yeah, yeah.
Isn't that something?
Now I I'm sure there's probably a proper word for people who go into caves.
It's uh what's what's what's the word for that?
Well, proper words a caver Uh some people call it spelunking, but uh we consider splunkers or the amateur cavers, uh Yeah.
The real cavers are just cavers.
I think it's pretty tight in some of those spots I bet, right?
Oh yeah.
Yeah, this particular one uh I was doing hologram, uh it had some really beautiful stuff in but you had to go through an awful lot of uh work to get to it and all the belly crawling it that was at least uh two hundred foot long I think.
Hmm.
But that's good because that keeps people out Yeah.
You have to be pretty dedicated to uh go through that much trouble to get back in there.
Now after you're in these uh these small passageways that you're you're crawling through, do you eventually wind up in like one of those large rooms or something?
Is that uh is that the whole point?
Yeah well these uh formations were uh it was a quite a large room and it's just full of these formations that are like uh made out of look like they're made out of uh cut glass or something so just transparent and uh particular formation I did the hologram I don't look like a little tiny Christmas tree and I believe it's called a ragonite the uh mineral that's made out of.
Mm-hmm.
It's just got a whole bunch of real shiny little points on it and it was just perfect uh very gently uh put a four by five inch uh holographic plate up against it and aim the laser through and shoot it.
Oh are you using Agha materials?
Right.
Yeah.
Yeah start trying to rush and stuff.
How are you with your uh supply?
Do you still have quite a few actual materials left?
No, and I guess maybe uh about a box and a half left of four by five inch plates and the one box of two by twos.
Some of the old uh film stock too.
That's uh probably the next trick I want to pull off is uh doing uh one of the uh cone shaped holograms.
Oh yeah.
You just place the cone right over the formation, I guess, right?
Set it on formation and now we only need to use a diode.
It shouldn't be any trouble to uh put the dye of the space filter all onto one small block of wood and can't leave it out on a some kind of a piece of pipe or something that would be a formation.
Isn't that something?
How many holograms would you say you've done that you have in your collection?
Maybe we've got a hundred or so.
And tried a few different uh multiplexes and uh that was uh one like big dreams is to try to make some nice multiplex holograms.
Yeah.
But uh that didn't really turn out really well but still it's thrilling just to do it and even get a crude image.
Do you uh belong to like a cave group that you show other people in the group the holograms and stuff?
Yeah, that's a national organization.
We have a local uh chapter here called a grotto that's uh that uh belong to something called National Philiological Society and I don't know how many thousands of people are in that group.
Uh if anybody's interested in caves they can go to the web and uh caves dot org would get you to the National Speleological Society and say you just had anything you want to know about caves and how to find your own local grotto.
Well there's gonna be a lot of them out there probably listening to this right now.
Do you ever put things together for an exhibit of your work?
Um I guess I'm just a bit uh shy about it or whatever.
Jeez, you should put something together.
That would be so well received.
Yeah.
Yeah well um we you know there are different national uh cave uh things that go on and all uh something coming up in about a month I was thinking about maybe uh displaying one of these there.
My local group that's scene is uh really raved about it.
Yeah.
Is this one that you made with the pointer or the uh laser I mean probably the uh shortly going back underground with the pointer now.
Yeah no I'm I'm going to put up a web page where people are actually starting to make the holograms now.
It was first, you know, Steve and I were doing it and then people would log on to the website and read about what we were doing.
And now they're starting to do on a on their own around the world.
And I'm going to put up a web page where you can see all the different work that people's been doing making holograms using the laser pointer.
I'd love to have a photograph of one of your pieces if it's possible.
So that I could put it on the web page.
Do you ever take photos of them?
No.
I don't know that much about cameras Yeah.
So your wife goes with you on these trips, huh?
Oh yeah.
Does she help you out with the holography?
Yeah.
Well uh last time I uh went and did some holograms she uh went along to help me out.
Um I wanted to try to make some holograms for my newsletter f for our local group, which uh fortunately it's uh I've only got a small amount of people in so the newsletter it would only be about uh maybe twenty or so uh issues.
Yeah.
So I wanted to try to make a master hologram and make some copies and all of them put on the cover of it.
You had to think well heck it's only that's a smaller amount.
Just drag that much film into the cave and do twenty twenty or thirty individual exposures.
Wow.
So I took uh forty pieces of film back there and it is that uh I don't know what the problem is there's only uh small number of 'em turned out even halfway decent.
Yeah.
Now how do you hold that glass together with clips?
Yeah, it's just clips.
Yeah.
I didn't use any kind of index matching fluids.
Well, it's one thing is the dusty environment, it's muddy and it's a mess back in the cave.
That's all you need to do is mess with some discus liquid too while you're back there.
So I just stand between glass and uh so you get the uh I guess you call it the Newton rings or whatever, yeah, the fridges.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
There you there you go.
Have you ever heard or worked with triethanolamine?
Yeah.
Because uh that actually pre-sensitizes the emulsion.
You may find out you get a little bit uh brighter result.
You could probably uh actually soak a couple plates, like five or six plates before you go down and have them already pre-treated when you just take them out of the box and do a shoot.
You give that a shot sometime.
That works especially nice with the laser pointer.
Uh the ones that I've shot using triethanol I mean are several times brighter than the ones that have not been treated and are just exposed out of the box.
Optimic exposure time it still comes out bright with triethylene?
Yeah.
I thought triathlon you must really just playing around with changing colors.
Yeah, it is it is basically but it it actually s uh sensitizes the emulsion yeah.
Uh hypersensitizes the emulsion.
Now what type of laser pointer are you using?
I think you sent me an email one time and said you didn't have much luck with it, right?
When it first started out.
'Cause I was uh running through a space filter and I figured it wouldn't be any good until I really got a decent uh pattern through my space filter and every one of them I used uh would never make a really nice pattern.
Uh it always had a little bit of uh left over diffraction in it.
So I'd say the heck with it so it's got a little diffraction in it.
I went ahead and tried it anyhow just amazed how beautiful came out.
No kidding.
Wow.
And how do you have the laser uh uh pointer set up?
Do you have it like uh is there a button that you have to press and you put a clip over that or something?
Yeah I just ran a piece of tape around that and put a couple uh alligator clips and took the batteries out laser pointer and stuck a couple of alligator clips into it to hook up to an external battery three uh C cells.
Oh you use C cells, huh?
Uh-huh.
Hmm.
Uh interesting somebody that has a lot of film to to uh experiment with 'cause I tr I tried not to experiment a whole lot 'cause I don't have that much film and uh just uh not use a shutter at all.
I mean like I see a helium neon you gotta have a certain amount of time for it to warm up and all get in a third one equilibrium though but diodes is it really a warm up time to them.
So you just uh just turn it on uh for a few seconds, turn it off?
There you go.
I did try that w uh the first two uh holograms try it with a laser diode one I used a hand shutter, just a piece of cardboard.
Mm-hmm.
I did try turning just turning on and uh turn it back off.
But neither one of those turned out too well.
Hm but uh what did you do different on the one that turned out really nice?
The third one that turned out nice is just being a little bit more careful and all letting it uh naturally dry before I took the hair dryer to it I guess.
Yeah that's real important too.
People don't realize what happens to that emulsion when you uh when you use a hairdryer and that that emulsion collapses.
Yeah.
So if you get a chance could you uh send me a couple of pictures of your holograms at some time.
Well heck I'm I'll just send you one of the holograms.
Alright, that would be great.
Because I'll tell you what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna put a show together of of laser pointer holography and uh let people have an opportunity to see uh what can be done with laser corners because this I don't want to sound off the wall but this is really a revolution.
You know, I mean I just I just picked up a ten milliwatt laser pointer uh not a pointer but a diode and just came in the mail today.
Yeah it just came if you used to get no I ha I have it set up but I haven't done any exposure with it yet.
I'm wondering if it's really as good as the laser pointers many laser suit pointers get some kind of a weird new laser diode in that just aren't in the modules.
Yeah well I'm not too crazy about the beam.
The beam is very rectangular on it.
And I'm having a really hard time with it, but I'm I'm gonna have to play around.
But uh for ten milliwatts, uh I was at a place today where they wanted one thousand two hundred and eighty dollars for a ten milliwatt heaning it's like there's no way you have to do that anymore.
I know, yeah.
Yeah, I got a you know me on upstairs, uh I think it's a spectrophysics one twenty four or something like that.
Mm-hmm.
That's I don't know what it is, like twenty five or thirty five milliwatt or something, but it died.
Oh yeah.
I called a couple of places and the best price I got so far was cost several hundred dollars to try to re gas the thing or whatever you have to do with Yeah.
But heck we got these diodes.
Why why even bother?
Yeah.
Well John, do you have anything you want to add to anything before we uh say goodnight here?
No, not really.
It's just uh anybody in your uh caving group you'd like to say hello to in case they log on and listen to this show?
Well yeah like uh thank uh Tom Molt and uh Buddy Wilker uh for all the help they have uh giving the uh help them carry the equipment back into the cave and all.
Now you how many people do you have with you when you're shooting these holograms in the cave?
Um maybe three or four.
Yeah.
And how long does it take to get to the place where you have to shoot it?
Uh you mean once you go into the cave and you Yeah, say you're on the outside of the cave you're just getting ready to go in.
How much time does it take to crawl through that area before you're in the area where you shoot the holograms?
Maybe a little over an hour or so.
Oh really?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, breath crawling quite a bit of I didn't expect every spots you gotta go to and sometimes it's uh got a little bit of water in it too.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's another thing too, is giving back what I'm doing shooting at the there's always a little bit of water dripping off the ceiling.
Mm-hmm.
So you have to do some protection that can keep you on the water from dropping right onto the lens of the space filter or something like that.
Yeah.
Or getting onto your plate too.
Water dripping on the plate before you even uh make an exposure.
If you do develop it, you've got nasty looking water spot on it.
Yeah.
Hmm.
I'm looking forward to seeing you just shoot a hologram for me and send it to me.
And I'll put it in with the collection.
And uh I'm gonna have a couple coming in from Norway.
These guys are just starting to shoot them now.
I I got an email from the one guy and uh he just wrote to me right in the middle of the night.
He he was just so happy in this email that he was able to uh shoot a beautiful hologram using a little laser pointer over there.
That's something.
Well I know, I'm excited.
I wasn't the other night.
I mean, uh outside, you know, running up and down the driveway, jumping around a little bit.
Well, John, thanks for being on the show.
And it's really unique what you're doing with holography.
When I get your hologram, I'm gonna take a photo of it here in the studio and get it up on the website so that everybody can uh see some of the work that you're doing.
That's very unique.
Well, John, thanks for being on the show.
Okay, thanks for watching.
Okay.